don't touch the red wire and then give
him us then slap muffled ooh you
shouldn't touch what anything John Jones
related that would be another thing now
you cook a little heat because you said
that well Jamie's cinnamon rolls cries
joking around yeah it's not that come on
you're like did anybody take a look at
that her name is I thought that was
funny
her name is cinnamon you're just being
silly God she is this it was a cow dude
she's a stripper an offensive tweet how
dare you she's not even a stripper she
just works there like what strip club
battery well here's my thing like so
with this it's like oh this is all I'm
saying
I just need more facts before we should
[ __ ] on whether it's John Jones Kevin
Spacey Bryan Callen Joe Rogan Theo von
if some came out whoever it is I know
John has check your background who and
rightfully so but whoever it is I'm not
gonna tell the US I'm not gonna tweet
you'll see you've gotta get rid of guys
Chris should be over because a waitress
at a strip club
that goes by a fake name says he choked
her there's no video there's no evidence
it's four months later there's witness
all four months later there's no video
severe there's nothing so yeah and also
here's a very careful testing Brian when
she came up you know it's John Jones I'm
fun at the strip club he slaps her I
guess in the [ __ ] she goes well if you
want to do that that's $100 sir so while
she she entertained it yeah so that's
what we're dealing with here all I'm
saying
John said he'd been serving his friends
for the duration of their evening at the
club the star fighter a portly request
to dance from her but she'd clarified
she was only away she's not a stripper
then she claimed Jones took things up a
notch and pulled her to his lap he then
began kissing her neck when she later
went to the bar to get shots for his
group Jones allegedly struck up snow
snot got behind her and put her in a
tight rear naked chokehold
the woman has gaped from the whole dole
she escaped but then Jones allegedly can
hit her up off the ground and turned her
around in the air and was roughhousing
with her she let her told the police it
felt like a wrestling match nothing
sexual
hmm he turned around
yeah he was but this was he became that
she said John Jones placed her down by
the bar and slapped her [ __ ] the woman
said she told Jones not to touch her in
that fashion but if you wanted to get to
pay for it if he was gonna smack her he
needed to pay her $100 which she told
John Hunt twice then she told the police
I think John Jones is a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] it is a bit particularly that the
club question would have a mayor hunter
dollar fee for the patrons to become
violent with the staff okay so first of
all first of all John lahum percent
shouldn't be I mean should be a strip
dude with your check it back crazy and
if you are gonna go there let's not do
any of this yeah that's not to any of
that but he shall lose a career over
this I'm I'm not ready just throw them
under the [ __ ] bus with these facts
and I have well I don't know what the
question is there's got to be video
surveillance right described that's what
we've been at some strip clubs yeah any
strip club there's always video yeah now
there's no video in the boom-boom room
there's no video in there that's where
everyone goes the boom-boom room for
that VIP experience yeah but there's
where he's out where they're saying the
bar there's cameras show me the footage
right show me the footage yeah uh I
think what you're saying is that there's
an allegation and it's not appropriate
this [ __ ] if he did all this stuff
that's a problem but I don't condone any
enero but at the same time I've I see
some evidence that's all you're saying
and is it is it that bad I went hold up
we're gonna crucify John Jones who's
done some horrible things is it is it
surprising they do this no but am I
gonna crucify this guy over a waitress
at a strip club who they don't have any
other evidence no it's a wait-and-see
thing right you got to be like wait hold
on before we throw them under the bus
and that's what I'm saying that's all
I'm saying because the media wants to
[ __ ] on him I'm not defending him but we
do know this could be any but we do live
in an environment where we're an
accusation or two can can actually cause
you to lose your job now let me tell you
this neil degrasse tyson we've seen that
all this that dose notes allegations
were unbelievable and have you had
you know ride up show have you seen a
ride up where someone goes actually this
was all [ __ ] never see me now have
you clicked on that now now now let's
say nothing comes of this do you think
yes PN and all these [ __ ]
journalists gonna write actually John
they do anything is just in the strip
club I'm fun
this girl's like John's a tough guy to
defend right so John John I'm not
defending John I'm defending anybody
yeah yeah that's I think you're saying
let's be careful but I'll tell you what
anything John just shouldn't touch he
has so many haters well just don't come
people are coming out or me and I was
like what now hold up hold up hold up
this could be literally anybody yeah I'm
just saying for a strip club waitress to
make these claims and there's no other
key witnesses in a crowded strip club or
a video I'm not ready to say John should
lose his job that's all whether he's a
fighter it's good if there's a Starbucks
I don't it would be good if there were
corroborating like witnesses and video
I'd like to see what you're asking for
us can I see some evidence before we
throat destroy his destroy his career
again but here's the other thing if you
show me video and those things are true
get him the [ __ ] out well I've 0/0 like
if he did all that as he did all that
see yeah yeah we can't have it yeah but
I'm without any evidence without just
taking a strip club
waitresses word on it with no other
evidence yeah then once and would she be
making iowa iowa thing would she be
making this claim as if his name was
Steve Jones yeah I don't know I think
that the I think that the main thing is
we do have to have evidence before we
did we throw somebody under the bus
and I think if you don't just remember
if you live in that world you're next
you're next because people there are
plenty of people that will do whatever
they can to get you out of the way but
but I still think with the internet
everyone's like yes yeah um whoa whoa
chill do yeah I know you guys need
something to do with your lives and the
hate they're like there's this hate club
and they want to direct the attention
towards that it's like dude but also at
least point your gun at something
worthwhile but also John of course don't
be in strip clubs and also I think a lot
of people are reacting to the fact that
he did hit a pregnant woman in a car and
ran away
and then came back and got his cash and
broke wrong there's so many things but
we're all like dude
uh I'm not again I'm not paying a person
that's horrible sure you're defending
the principle yes could be John the [ __ ]
could be Tom Brady which i think is nice
one
don't care what I'm saying let's say
those accusations came out at chin let's
say happen to my girl let's say my girl
was like a man and let's say she was the
the the strip club waitress like hey I
came in John did all this even no micro
I'm like is anyone I'll see it you have
any video your pictures just cuz you
wanna yeah I'm like a needle like what
are we gonna do need who I saw at the
club you like you tell me that pack
strip club no one else saw and all those
people you think all's people love John
Jones people can't want to see Jon Jones
burn man
yeah so you tell me no one else saw this
I don't know man well it's not I don't
know at the bottom line is you need all
that you have to have you got to
something you have to say so there's no
evidence is as surfaced
no if anything I think Jones's team said
that they have people like waitresses in
whatever that our witnesses that want
his side that's interesting
and but don't boo hmm I would imagine
the club would have maybe that videotape
erases after a short period of time this
is for later this happened four months
ago and now the surface April April slit
and yes she filed a complaint now I
guess so he found out through a news
agency that something happened were huh
yeah he had to pay a fee because if
something happened here's my other thing
like it 200 other feet I don't think
anything's gonna come from come up this
and and here's my tea this my problem
with the media how many people are gonna
write that nothing came from this and
that girl's full of [ __ ] they won't not
one and yet all you [ __ ] are throwing
everyone under the bus without any real
evidence that was the point of my tweet
this is going on all the time that's
what I'm saying be but whether it's John
John Jones is in my wheelhouse right
yeah he's in he's in what I do so when
it whether it's John whether it was
Conor McGregor whether it was Chris
Weidman Brian Bader named Amy fighter I
would have said the same thing but the
reason Johnny so much hate is because
his checkered past
yes but I'm saying take your blindness
hate away from John he might trigger in
so many ways
you hate him for all those things take
that away if it was
just a regular dude we wouldn't be like
that yes they're just doing it because
there's it what you can't do well um
there's so much of that that goes on
like people were very quick to interpret
something and label it and I think
that's always a mistake my problem is
like this [ __ ] culture we live in a
woman and really it's the extreme right
even with politics like the the the 1%
kind of sway the nirvan online which is
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]